all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test let's do it
it will
a grim reaper scythe
oh
no oh that's great
the grim reaper scythe is the grisly
weapon of death whose legend traces back
to the dark days of the bubonic plague
in the 14th century
at that time scythes were common farm
implements whose razor sharp blades were
used to reap large fields of grass or
crops
so it's natural that they would be
recast as death's tool since he is the
reaper of souls
occasionally rebellious peasants would
also turn their deadly sides on each
other
as lethal offensive weapons
scythes feature a large curved blade
jutting from the top of the shaft or
snap
and two short handles for gripping
popular culture sides are now the
prevalent symbol for death
as evidenced in movies ranging from the
frighteners to bill and ted's bogus
journey to the meaning of life
late smiths this is the kill test the
grim reaper uses the scythe to harvest
the souls of humans when it's their time
to test the lethality of your scythe i
will take your scythe
and try to rip out the soul of these
ballistics dummies
chase you up first you ready ready as
i'll ever be let's do this
[Music]
damn
all right chase let's talk about your
scythe right here the edge
is sharp your tip punctures deep
breaking ribs and right into the heart
pulling out its soul
this weapon sir
it will kill good job thank you
all right brandon your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this let's do it
[Applause]
oh
that is awesome
all right bran let's talk about your
scythe right here
aside from reaping the soul out of this
ballistics dummy i seem to have taken
the clavicle and sternum with it your
point here really digs in but in doing
so and hitting the bone you have a
little chip right here at the tip
i don't know and one
on the blade right there
but most importantly
it will deal there it is thank you sir
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your sides i've affixed them to our
forged in fire coffin
oh god and i will be batoning your edge
many many times
remember this test is all about what the
batons do to the sides and not what the
scythes do to the batons
chase you're up first you ready all
right
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
chase your blade suffered a catastrophic
failure on the fourth strike
you know what that means right we can no
longer continue testing your blade
however brandon
your blade needs to survive four strikes
of that baton in order for you to become
the forged and fire champion
ben
rennie you ready for this
yes sir let's do it
brandon congratulations your blade
survived
chase unfortunately your blade has
suffered a catastrophic weapons failure
and will no longer continue in this
competition and for that reason i have
to ask you to please shake your
competitor's hand and leave the forge
i had a really great time doing all this
right now it's kind of hard to express
that
but i really have had a great time
brandon congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion and you'll be
reaping a check for 10 000 good job
brother thank you so much hell yeah i
love it
i feel great
this is absolutely unbelievable to me
i mean i want to say my family guys i
did it and i'm coming home
my name is brandon williams i'm from
blackfoot idaho i'm the new fortune fire
champion
hell yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
a pair of frankish throwing axes
the frankish throwing axe was the deadly
and iconic weapon of germanic tribes
known as the franks during the 3rd
century masters of shock and awe combat
the franks carried multiple axes in
battle and would throw them at close
range to break formation and cause chaos
the ax's heavy blade and razor sharp
edge cut deep into enemy flesh and was
capable of damaging armor and crushing
bone the x's brutality in the hands of
the franks are still prevalent in movies
and can be seen in the 2010 film
centurion
all right bladesmiths well frankly your
frankish throwing axes look fantastic
but are they lethal well to find that
out i will take your weapons and deliver
some well
hellish of a blow on this ballistics
dummy
justin you're up first you ready split
it to the teeth
[Music]
[Music]
all right justin every chop and slash is
deep overall sir it'll kill thank you
all right nick it's your turn ready to
have fun let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
all right nick upon impact
crushes the face easily in the head
your edges they dig in with every chop
and slash
it'll kill thanks doc good job
[Music]
blade smiths welcome to the strength
test
i will be
throwing your frankish throwing axes
into this large wall
justin you're up first you ready for
this yeah bud let's do it
well justin there is
a ding
on this blade right here where my finger
is your handles are comfortable the
problem i have with them this bulb is
more fitted for a fighting axe as
retention a throwing axe you kind of
want to let it go
but in all your axes held up nice job
thank you
nick you're up you ready for this let's
do this
[Music]
well nick your edges
held up great i can't even tell that
they've been thrown handles
show no damage nice job
all right bladesmiths this is our
sharpness test the foot soldier attack
this is all about what the edges of your
weapon will do on the protective
clothing of this foot soldier justin
you're up first you ready
yeah kill it
all right justin your edges over here as
you can see on the clothing on this it
cuts right into this foot soldier
overall sir your weapons
it will cut go
all right nick your turn sir you ready
play some good music
all right nick no glinting or rolls are
your edges
sharp with every cut that went through
it'll cut
thank you
all right blade smiths you guys have
brought in some high quality competitive
and nicely matched frankish throwing
axes but only one of you can be the
forged and fire champion
nick congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion justin unfortunately
your frankish throwing axes did not make
the cut
justin both sets of axes performed well
on all of our tests so this basically
came down to that small amount of damage
you took in the strength test and the
overall design of your axes
yes here
justin you did a great job but at this
time i have to ask you to please
surrender your blades
[Music]
i just came here i did good
i think i represented myself well and i
think if nothing else these tests show
that i can make a working blade
nick congratulations you're the forest
of fire champion and that's a title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job man please present your
axes to the judges
this experience was
incredible i had so much fun
i came here to win for my mom she was my
biggest fan and i've done exactly
what i plan to do
oh my gosh
i didn't mom
a locker bar axe
the locker bear axe was the weapon of
choice for the famed scottish
highlanders during the 1600s
featuring a large two foot blade affixed
to a wooden pole this pole arm was
simple in its design yet lethal on and
off the battlefield containing a
pronounced hook mounted at the tip of
the shaft this deadly weapon could
unmount soldiers from their horses with
a single blow they would brutally finish
the enemy with either the head of the
axe or with its sharp fatal edge this
medieval weapon still sees virtual
combat in video games like assassin's
creed unity all right bladesmiths this
is the kill test now to find out how
lethal your weapons are i will take your
locker bar so they'll be killing blows
on this big carcass
joshua you're up first you ready for
this yeah let's do it
okay
all right joshua first up your blade
it's a pork chopper on its thrust you
see the wound channel it creates such a
big deep gash
it's fun to wield
it's sharp and most importantly
it will kill good job thank you
all right jesse your turn are you ready
absolutely let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
first up your blade has to wait that
every chop into something want to keep
going it wants to keep going and going
and going to where
pretty much took me with it good chops
good cuts and more importantly
it will kill
thank you all right up next the strength
test dave
to test the strength and overall
construction of your weapons i'll be
hooking the shield pulling it into place
and then attacking it with the blade
all right josh you're up first you ready
oh yeah
[Music]
so first off you took a little bit of
deformation here pretty much
where that edge caught some of the studs
on that shield
but
it's still sharp
it's really a nicely built piece got a
good look to it it's easy to wield
everything's still solid
strong axe nicely done
thank you all right jesse your turn you
ready absolutely
so
all right jesse
you can see on your blade here
where
you've taken a pretty good roll here and
this is sort of a roll and a chip
but
everywhere else on this blade still
sharp nicely done thank you
all right gentlemen next up the
sharpness test for that i'll give you
the doug
this is the sugarcane slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are i will take your weapons and deliver
cuts across these sugarcane bundles
joshua first ready for this let's do it
man let's do it
all right joshua you contoured this
shaft here so that when you hold on to
it you can really tell where the edge is
i really like that
overall sir your weapon is sharp it cuts
all the way through cleanly it will cut
thank you
all right jesse your turn you ready you
betcha
yeah
all right jesse
the blade
is heavy it cuts but also you can feel
the weight behind it crush the rest of
it overall sir for this test
it will cut
thank you
josh jesse both of you guys brought in
finale weapons that performed incredibly
well in our tests only one of you can be
the forest and fire champion and that
champion is
josh congratulations you're the force
and fire champion jesse unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut
jesse you brought us a fantastic weapon
and this came down to the finest of
details your weapon took a bit more
damage and your opponent's weapon was a
little bit lighter and easier to control
for those reasons we're letting you go
all right jesse please surrender your
weapon
i came here to prove to myself that i'm
not uh you know just a backyard knife
maker and i'm ecstatic that i made it
this far
all right josh congratulations you're
the forest and fire champion and that's
a title that comes with a check for 10
000 good job brother
yeah it's amazing it's an amazing
feeling please present your blade to the
judges
what
are you kidding
holy crap
i'm a fortune fire champion
i'm i'm
speechless
the darp street gun chai
the darp sri gun chai is a massive
double-handed sword used in thailand
during the 18th century featuring a long
single edge slightly curved blade with a
flame back spine the weapon was designed
to inflict devastating blows and slashes
on enemies measuring it nearly five feet
long this blade was so large and
intimidating it was used by guards in
the northern kingdom of lana now
northern thailand to scare off potential
intruders this frightening weapon can be
seen in the 2007 movie kingdom of war
part 2.
welcome to the kill test your dark
street gunshots look intimidating but
are they deadly to find that out i will
take your weapon deliver some killing
blows in this ballistic stomach
james you're up first you ready for this
there's nothing i can do to stop it all
right let's do it
all right james
first up that's a beast
it's very forward heavy so it definitely
feels like a chopper all the way through
now your handle here by adding this fur
around it i can't get a good grip on it
because it's so soft
now your edge
is sharp
overall sir
it will kill thank you all right paul
your turn so you ready i'm ready let's
do this
[Music]
all right paul first up i really
appreciate the damascus pattern that you
brought out here
now
the fact that i can hold the weapon out
extended like this shows just how light
this weapon is for its size and because
of that i can cut deeply into this
without using the weight just velocity
alone but after that striking skull just
picked up a little bit of a bend overall
sir it'll keel thank you
[Music]
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
i'll be chopping into these pots
now remember this is not about what your
blades do to the targets but what the
targets can do to your blades
james you have first you ready let it
happen okay
this is a shoulder ripping monster
once you start this thing moving
stopping it is really rough on the
shoulders the fur around the middle here
it's a neat look but it's very slick
actually
and then your edge
is still sharp you nailed it good job
thank you
all right paul you're up you ready yup
okay
good job dude thanks
all right paul right off this weapon has
a feel that is excellent i can literally
use it with one hand
the edge
still sharp nicely done thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths to see how sharp
your weapons are i will try to cut
through these pineapples
james your first you ready for this
let's go let's do this
nice nice
all right james
just a little off the top
your edge is sharp cuts cleany all the
way through these pineapples
it will cut thank you all right paul
your turn ready yep
there you go man gosh
all right paul
it is razor sharp just the thinness of
your metal here cuts through no
resistance if you get the pineapple
heads they're all still standing right
there it's very sharp and more
importantly
build a cut thank you
james paul you've both done an
incredible amount of work however there
can only be one forged and fire champion
in this competition and that champion is
paul congratulations you're the new
foreign fire champion
james
your blade just didn't make the cut and
david baker is going to tell you why
james we had a long discussion about
this and what it comes down to
is that rabbit fur made a very slippery
grip and all that weight in that blade
made it hard to stop once you started
swinging it that's why we're letting you
go
james please surrender your gun chai
it's been a really great experience i
did the best i could no matter what you
do in life there's going to be
challenges and you're not going to
always succeed
just get back up get back on the horse
paul congratulations you're the forge
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with the check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
thank you thank you
i just couldn't be happier this is like
gotta be the craziest thing that's ever
happened to me so far i mean i know i'm
only 19 but i still can't believe it i'm
the forage and fire champion and it
feels incredible
[Applause]
the dousage
yes
dating back to the 16th century the
dousage began as a military sidearm for
german troops mimicking the blade of a
saber combined with the hilt of a
broadsword it's curved design delivered
deadly hacks and slices while its basket
hilt provided protection in close
quarters combat
featuring a wide single-edged blade its
double-sided fuller kept it light for
quick maneuvering similar to the cutlass
this sword was favored by pirates and
naval officers because they were easy to
conceal and quick to draw this
intimidating sword can be seen in the
2016 tv series black sails
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill
test to find out what kind of lethal
damage your friend will do i'll take
your weapon deliver some slashes of
thrust on this big carcass scott you're
up first you ready for this oh yeah
let's do this
[Music]
oh
all right scott first up it is light the
balance really allows for velocity and
recovery with this blade and most
importantly
it will kill
yeah all right mark your turns are you
ready heck yeah let's do this
[Music]
he's just hanging there like chewing gum
all right talk about your blade here
it's beautiful in its creation the edge
is sharp i was quite amazed with the
cuts i was surprised that it cut that
deeply the one thing though is that that
guard right there there rubs on my
knuckle not bad but it does rub on the
knuckle despite that it will kill yes
[Music]
all right gentlemen
welcome to the strength test the whiskey
barrel chop
yeah now to test the strength and
overall construction of your swords i
will be swinging into these whiskey
barrels scott you're up first you ready
for this oh yeah all right
first off scott this thing is still
a razor blade on its entire length
except for right there you did take a
bit of a roll there and a very small
chip but beautiful craftsmanship super
light fast blade and very strong nicely
done thank you
mark you're up next are you ready for
this smash them okay
here she goes
all right mark
got an edge all the way across this
thing he didn't lose a bit
the only issue i have with this weapon
at all is doug said
my knuckle
rides right there on the inside of the
guard it's not chewing my hand up but
there is contact right there where i
don't necessarily want it it's a
beautiful weapon it's strong nicely done
thank you
all right bladesmith this is the
sharpest test the four pillars slice
these pillars are wrapped in different
materials foam leather canvas and silk
scotch here first ready for this oh yeah
[Music]
all right scott's talking about your
weapon here it is light every cut it
cuts nicely overall sir
it will cut thank you all right mark
onto your shiny sword you ready for this
slice and dice
all right mark's talking about your
blade here
that's a cutter right there you can feel
the weight of the power with your
slashes with this on the leather it did
cut
it's just because thicker kind of blade
that you have here to cut all the way
through but overall sir
it will cut
nice
mark scott both of you guys turned in
incredibly competitive blades however
the judges have completed their
deliberation they've made their final
decision our new forged and fire
champion is
scott congratulations
mark unfortunately the judges have
decided that your blade doesn't make the
cut please surrender your blade
that was a fine piece man going home
because my guard was rubbing the judge's
knuckles just a slight bit that little
teeny tiny detail you live and you learn
well scott in one of our tightest
competitions to date you've become the
forest and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job
thank you thank you ah
i won baby yes
this ranks up there with getting married
having children oh yeah i'm a fortune
fire champion too by the way what's next
for me um get my 10 grand in one so i
can roll around in it you know normal
stuff you know what normal champions do
you